revenu aux sources du lavandou avec
notre famille on a décidé de suivre de
nouvelles lois celle de la m le potager
un dépôt d'avis parce qu'il y en a
plusieurs sur le terrain on signe aussi
beaucoup de plantes sauvages lortie
s'est quasiment notre aliments de base
avec la noix et la pomme qui sont des
ressources locales qu'on a en abondance
portions on a souvent l'impression que
c'est une mauvaise herbe alors qu'en
fait c'est notre meilleure amie
alors moi j'ai mis beaucoup de temps
avant de le réaliser mais en réalité
même lorsqu'on marche on fait une petite
rando et tous ces sources de protéines
énorme donc en fait d'un seul est plié
de façon à retirer tous les petits poils
pour ensuite me manger directement dans
la bouche mais on peut en faire plein de
place et aussi ronde l'année même pas
mal c'est de la récupération
voilà l'un dans l'autre ça fait que on a
une espèce d'autonomie alimentaire assez
facile
[Musique]
donc là on arrive dans l'atelier si on
apprend à faire plein de choses aussi et
notamment basque avec les ressources de
terrain de la vénerie des cuillères
faire fabriquer moins cher on vient sans
mal de la ville et celle qu'on a on a
l'habitude de travailler avec nos
cerveaux beaucoup plus et donc là on
veut essayer de rodez faire redescendre
un peu cette énergie vers les mains
alors cet autre intelligence et de faire
voilà dans l'âge de fer et le faire
ensemble ça fait aussi sa développe
aussi une notre intelligence c'est
l'intelligence émotionnelle et du coup
il ya aussi tout un travail intérieur
quand tu vis en collectif quand tu vis
dans la nature la forêt ya quelque chose
de vraiment d'un prospectus et et
surtout de vivre avec les autres au
quotidien même avec les animaux quoi
faire une espèce de d'humilité qui vient
quand tu vis avec aller sans oublier les
chevreuils et les serpents donc de
balaté on est plus on n'est plus des
rois de la jungle mais surtout on est
plus de déconnecter en fête de l'eau et
du vivant et ce qui fait que ça engendre
un respect croissant aussi pour cette
nature
[Musique]
ces cabanons vallée réaliser simplement
avec des matériaux qu'on va trouver donc
dans notre périmètre
voilà les pierres ont été transportés
avec brouette depuis d'une convenir à un
mur qui s'écroule et la 300 m la terre
c'est de la terre qu'on a renfloué pour
faire la rigole de la cabane qu'on a nié
pour faire la plateforme entre les
pierres la paille
on l'a trouvée chez la voisine qui
faisait des petites bottes de foin les
bambous pour le brochet les bottes de
paille
on les a trouvés donc la bambouseraie
que j'ai planté est à peu près 12 15 ans
une cabane comme celle dans laquelle on
vit fait 35 mètres carrés je pense que
si on dit 1000 euros on est très large
voilà en gros un loyer parisien d'un
petit appart on me dit qu'on construit
une cabane il doit on peut vivre tout le
temps dedans
voilà
nous
tout est là
[Musique]
oh
la désobéissance civile elle est hyper
intéressante parce que elle va chercher
à pointer du doigt à se mettre en
désobéissance par rapport à ce qui ce
passe de mal dans les institutions en
vue de corriger l'institution et nous
notre philosophie avec la désobligeance
certes il est laid nous dire on va faire
un peintre un pas de côté parce que les
institutions aujourd'hui c'est clair que
non seulement elles permettent pas de
résoudre les problèmes des pires encore
c'est peut-être elle qui cautionnent
aussi toutes les destructions les
extractions au profit du profit de
l'accumulation de richesses justement
souvent les personnes lorsqu'elles vont
habiter quelque part à qu'elle achète
elle s'endette parce que il faut avoir
un terrain constructible un terrain
constructible ça coûte dix fois vingt
fois plus cher qu'un terrain non
constructible
il ya ça déjà et est ensuite de quoi
faut demander des permis de construire
faut se conformer à certaines heures
certaines sommes souvent très
contraignant et qui plus est qui sont
très polluantes parce que aujourd'hui
quasiment toute la construction
traditionnelle elle est faite en
parpaings de béton nous d'extraction de
ressources ensuite qui font des déchets
à n'en plus finir
aujourd'hui la loi elle a permis à ce
qu'on pollue la plupart de nos cours
d'eau de lothaire de notre ère alors si
la loi elle permet ça bah oui clairement
on va arrêter de subir la loi et on va
créer des formes de vie voilà lundi dans
des habitats qui sont quasiment de
dégrader de la par les fenêtres
portables qui sont compostables que qui
sont aigre totalement dans la nature
bondi avec la nature alors si la loi le
permet pas start
nous on veut que les gens ils habitent
dans la forêt voilà aujourd'hui on est
en train de détruire la forêt en france
maintenant il ya plus que 16 % de forêts
à peu près sauvage tout le reste
la moitié de ces forêts lassé des
exploitations forestières où on bombarde
du ps de pesticides et nous par exemple
rien de notre région dans le limousin et
bas de ces forêts sauvages ont détruit 1
million de mètres carrés par an nous ce
qu'on veut c'est que les gens y vivent
dans ces forêts là quels qu'en soient
les lois les constructibles non
constructibles non veux qu'ils aient des
gardiens pour la forêt voilà qu'on veut
plus qu'on la détruisent et donc c'est
ça la désobéissance carte il sait vivre
dans la forêt avec l'accord heures
[Musique]